here's a top seven reasons why Apple is
so successful and we're starting right
now with number one simplicity and their
purpose alcohol has always kept
everything very simple from their
original iMac to their current max books
and this is what makes all of their
parts very clean and sleek let's be
honest here it is really annoying that
you have to buy an adapter just to plug
in a USB to your 12 under MacBook but at
the same time it is a removal of those
ports that make the MacBook so thin and
elegant and this concept carries on
throughout their entire product lineup
from their PC there's simple cylinders
through our new iPhones that don't even
have home buttons or headphone jacks
Apple is always trying to reduce reports
and buttons to keep your parts as simple
and straightforward as possible and it
is not just a product themselves but the
whole product structure for so long the
iPhone is only offered in black and
white nowadays there's a lot more
variety but the options are still pretty
limited when it goes to Apple each of
their options are carefully chosen and
have a clear target demographic for
MacBooks you can get a MacBook Air if
you're a light user or a heavy traveler
the MacBook is perfect for the average
user who wants a bit bigger screen and
some more power
finally the MacBook Pros for the power
user who wants the best there is and
there's just a few colors and
specifications to choose from each level
so it really is just that simple there's
simple design and uncomplicated product
line up has to find them over the past
couple of decades and is a hugely
differentiating factor from their
competitors well beyond to number two
this is the second of most important
reason what Apple is so successful and
departure so desirable and that is that
the people who create Apple products
want the product for themselves a lot of
times you will see company CEOs and
workers not even using products that
they are creating while these CEOs and
workers do try their
best to relate with the customer and
think about what they would want is
completely different than wanting a
product for themselves Apple all the
stuff love the price that they create
and wouldn't buy anything else for
themselves it is hard to find an Apple
employee who doesn't have an Apple watch
MacBook and
iPhone themselves and it's not just
because they're getting discounts from
Apple but because they truly do enjoy
using the products themselves an Apple
only hires employees with have this
vision and strong passion for Apple
products and this next Apple very strong
from Johnny I've designing a phone that
you would want to use those top quality
metals and glass to hundreds of
developers who create a user interface
that they think is not only beautiful
but easy to navigate and understand it
is this innate passion that Apple
employees have for their own products
and make their price more desirable for
the public as well all right number
three Apple only makes a product if they
know that they can make it better as
Johnny IFS set himself our goals are
very simple to design and make a better
products if we can't make something
better we won't do it
Apple knows exactly what they're good at
and won't do anything else
for example Apple knows that they are
not good at making gaming computers but
I simply just don't do it
gamers expect a lot of customization and
nowadays RGB and tempered glass are also
very nice touch that many cameras want
this is simply not what Apple aims to
offer with their parts like I discussed
in 0.1 alcohol likes to keep things
simple and are definitely not interested
in adding RGB enterprise and as a result
they steer clear from this market
oftentimes competitors don't exactly
launch products that are better than
their competitors but instead pretty
much the same master competitors for
pretty much the same price as well now
there is nothing wrong with doing this
it is just that this prevents these
companies from really sticking out and
anyone arena Apple completely avoids
this trap by never launching a product
in direct competition with her
competitors instead they always launch
products that are better than their
competitors which are by nature also
more expensive as a result from the
customers point of view it is never a
choice between design and whatever is
cheaper at the time of purchase but
instead why I want to spend a good
amount of money and get a nice part or
spend a little bit more money and get a
top-flight product and clearly a lot of
people around the world want
top-of-the-line products and this is a
lot Apple to build a large customer base
and these customers all bought apples
parks because they truly wanted them not
just because that was what was cheaper
when they were buying a laptop or phone
and that brings me in to point number
four Apple is always working on the
future as I mentioned in point number
three Apple is not directly competing
with their competitors as a result Apple
is not concerned with what Samsung
brings with the new Galaxy phones
instead they're busy working on what
people want in two to four years from
right now the new iPhone that will come
out this year was pretty much finalized
and signed off about it year and a half
ago right now they're working on
finalizing the details for the phone
that's going to be coming out in 2020
it's turning development while the 2021
phone and this is not just Apple many
different companies in many different
fields uses exact same strategy the most
notable being Jeff Bezos from Amazon he
says that he is always working three
years into the future whatever a friend
congratulate him on a great quarter he
thanks them and tells them this Porter
was already baked three years ago and he
is currently making a batter for the
cake that is going to be big in three
years and this is crucial but if this
enables Apple to shift their focus away
from what their competitors are
releasing into what they think the
public will want this is a very simple
concept and lost Apple to always stay
one step ahead of their competitors and
ensure that their parents not influenced
by anyone else
moving on number five Apple has been
able to build outstanding brand loyalty
mainly through their stellar customer
service there are stories of Apple
charging notoriously high prices for
easy repairs but for the most part Apple
has a really great customer service
the main factor allowing for this is
again passionate employees where else do
you see people lining up days in advance
to buy the newest iPhone created by
enthusiastic young knowledgeable staff
members who are just as excited about
the products they literally clap and
play music I'm not sure how much more
consumer-friendly you could really get
and whenever you have an issue with your
iPhone they're more than happy to help
you resolve it and there are several
stories of people going in for repairs
and getting a free replacement phone I
think that it is clear that while Apple
does charter pretty penny for repairs
their top notch service is definitely
match at the high price plus they're
more than willing to repair or even
replace your phone for free if it truly
is their fault this outstanding customer
service and stellar products have a lot
of Apple to build a strong customer base
with strong brand loyalty number six one
of the biggest reasons for Apple's
outstanding financial success and
domination of the fortune 500 list is to
really hide those profit margins which
are almost 40 percent even that their
revenue is about 40 to 50 billion
dollars every single year it is clear
how this can stack up to a lot of money
very quickly
Apple has built themselves a premium
name and as a result people are willing
to spend more money for Apple products
even though they know they're overpaying
because they also know that Apple parts
are positive they can't find anywhere
else and finally before I move on to the
top reason that Apple is so successful I
can't go there without mentioning Steve
Jobs Steve Jobs is single-handedly
aren't the most influential people at
Apple and top him Apple may not even
exist today they may have gone bankrupt
in the early 2000s and closed form for
Steve Jobs iPod Steve Jobs poured his
heart and soul into
for many decades even working for one
dollar per year so as we discussed
apples outstanding success and how they
are able to become the first company to
hit or trillion dollar valuation let's
not forget about the man made all
possible Steve Jobs and of course Steve
Wozniak as well finally the most
important reason Apple is able to garner
so many sales is because they reinvent
products they don't exactly create
something new or unique but the way that
they approach existing products
revolutionizes the way that people
interact with these devices for example
Apple diamond computers but their masks
are a one-of-a-kind experience they
didn't invent phones but their iPhone
brought computer-like power into a
handheld device as it is evident the way
that up or reinvent these popular parts
is what attracts millions of customers
every year and even it convinces them to
spend more money on Apple products over
competitor products it is the Flair that
Apple parks have their simplicity
elegance flawless software along with
outstanding customer service that
persuade consumers to spend the extra
money for an Apple Park and Akita app
was able to maintain such a high profit
margins and high sales and pulling
billions of dollars every single year
however recently app was ever increasing
revenue has seen some drop in their
golden formula has produced some
disappointments if you are interested in
two top reasons that Apple has recently
been on a downfall and make sure check
out my dedicated video on that also if
you have liked to be the miserable like
and consider subscribing if you see more
videos just like this one well then
No
[Music]